banques feront bien de sauver même sauvé
dépêche-toi bien sûr mais viennent
sauver franc vis-à-vis bien vivante et
bouge toi son tour à ses premiers jo ah
oui
[Musique]
le premier défi ce sera le stop piétons
faudra aller dans la rue rendre un
passant sur son dos et le ramener à moi
le plus vite possible
salim et contre jaune le premier qui
revient avec quelqu'un sur son dos un
passant fait gagner un an de shopping
si vous gagnez c'est pour vous la danse
shopping si vous perdez on replace têtu
de port perry qui gagnent là notre
shopping d'accord attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
en fait t'as pas dû que des pistes et
jusqu'au les surmonte vite fait si vous
faire gagner quelque chose
le centre et au salut
aulas à lui
[Applaudissements]
va falloir faire un self qu un sérieux
c'est à dire la falloir prendre le
téléphone de quelqu'un dans la rue et
faire à celle vécue d'accord minuk nu
dans nos bacs en mêlant battu d'une
attention va voir qu'est ce que ne fait
de ce qui va affronter salim tout de
suite du jeu on espère plus d'attention
soir
[Applaudissements]
attends attends tu entends je vois bien
qu'apparaissant police retenant pas
génial comment tu me dit monsieur vous
ensuite il faut tenir les imaginales
elle n'avait toujours pas et passer en
mode d'achat cette alim tu peux faire
une photo de mon cul cul s'il vous plaît
génial mais dites moi la fête - faute au
manque quelque chose dont vous faites
avec les dictatures vers éducation et la
pauvre je vous ramène ses lumières seul
mais c'est gagné sally bigham
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben justement trop rapide j'ai une photo
devant quelques bisous avant va être une
personne du même sexe
on peut lui faire de vous faire un bisou
d'accord salim
on va jouer pour un très beau cadeau
saline pour l'instant qu'ils savent pas
où aller ni très forts se passerait bien
attention c'est parti
c'est parti c'est parti oh non attention
vous jouez au du même sexe garçons sont
partis c'est bon en q3 bien de sauver
même soulevé dépêche-toi bien même sauvé
vienne sauver francs très vite la vitre
et belges toi je pèche par son retour à
ses premières démos ah oui il a droit
m
il attendait je n'ai pas le choix qu'ils
ont fait le chemin piéton le patron
merci donc à tourner la page
c'est pas mal et hop accueillir sa libre
à bombay
plus on salue
si nous allons jouer
merci bonsoir et merci mon chéri da
[Musique]